population two pals all Americans have
to pay taxes every ten years but many of
us end up paying too much in taxes we
actually have a funny joke which is that
the IRS actually stands for everyone
really
scant shouldn't you have such a simple
formula so you don't overpay it's so
simple it's almost too simple it's well
it's it's fine you're gonna take a piece
of scrap paper at the top of that piece
of paper you're gonna put your incomes
and your direct deposits and then you're
gonna divide that by your dependents and
your durables and that's just normal
write-off stuff like regular taxes
fences fashions groceries so any money
you get tricked out of is an immediate
read off anything you lost in a scam or
a scheme a grift a swindle a Monti a
high/low a short cut a long time though
long cons are a little confusing because
that you might have to file an extension
for for me when I get long con I usually
end up losing that money over a period
of many years uh taxes yeah money that
fell mm-hmm bow taxes you know maybe
your cousin is like we should get a boat
together and you're like I've never even
met you and then yeah you don't know
where your cousin is you don't know what
your boat is like I'll find the boat
I'll find a cousin but you know bills
are coming to you so write that off and
then in a separate column you're gonna
put your business expenses so for
example let's say you spend $12,000 on a
globe bar you just put that in your
video and now it's a write-off hmm so
now you've got all these figures and you
just add minus them up and that final
number that you get that's the taxes you
owe to the government and as we all know
taxes pay for schools so you give that
money to a child